bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP c'est ça
vous regarde en direct et je suis ravi
de vous retrouver une Question à la Une
ce soir faut-il inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution après
sa remise en cause par la Cour suprême
américaine aux États-Unis ce droit
est-il menacé en France peut-être pas
aujourd'hui mais peut-être demain alors
faut-il le mettre à l'abri en le
sanctuarisant dans la loi fondamentale
de propositions de loi oblige les
députés à se positionner clairement dans
les jours qui viennent grand débat à
suivre avec nos invités sur ce plateau
dans un instant prolifique voilà un mot
qui va bien notre grand témoin ce soir
86 livres plusieurs vies et toujours
cette soif de comprendre le monde qui
évolue cette fois c'est sur l'éducation
qu'il s'est penché comment réparer
l'école et de quelle façon c'est elle
construite à travers les siècles Jacques
Attali publie histoire et à venir au
pluriel de l'éducation chez Flammarion
il sera avec nous dans la deuxième
partie enfin nos affranchis ce soir le
parti pris de Richard sur Mayotte au
bord de la guerre civile l'oeil sur le
numérique de Delphine Sabatier attention
supporters au Qatar vous êtes surveillé
enfin le regard sur la guerre d'Isabelle
Lasserre quand le conflit en Ukraine
mais les stocks d'armes américaines sous
pression voilà pour le menu ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
il y a des débats où les lignes
politiques bougent et plutôt vite celui
qu'on va avoir ce soir sur l'inscription
du droit à l'IVG en est un bonsoir Sarah
tanzili et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes député renaissance du Rhône bonsoir
Sandra rogol ravi de vous retrouver vous
êtes député Europe Écologie Les Verts
membres de la nupaisse députée du
Bas-Rhin bonsoir Jean-Philippe Tanguy
bienvenue à vous députés rassemblement
national de la Somme et puis Gada à
thème qui est gynécologue vous la
connaissez sur moi elle est venue
souvent sur ce plateau à la fondée la
maison des femmes à Saint-Denis viendra
nous rejoindre dans quelques petites
minutes bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
tout
de suite si j'ai bien compris c'est
parti
[Musique]
alors c'est un sujet important c'est un
sujet très politique aussi si j'ai bien
compris ce soir
régalés sur ce sujet donc si j'ai bien
compris Myriam le 24 juin dernier
l'avortement est redevenu légal illégal
pardon dans une vingtaine d'États aux
États-Unis ces liens décision de la
course suprême et vous devez vous en
souvenir ça avait susciter d'énormes
manifestations justement devant la Cour
suprême à Washington pour des véritables
il y avait une onde de choc à ce propos
alors dans ma jeunesse ce qui se passait
aux États-Unis ça mettait quoi deux
trois ans pour arriver en France en gros
aujourd'hui mais c'est beaucoup plus
rapide dès le lendemain de la décision
de la Cour suprême et bien Aurore berger
qui est la présidente du groupe
Renaissance décidait qu'il fallait
changer la Constitution française celle
de la 5ème République en écoute je crois
que cette situation nouvelle elle mérite
évidemment non pas juste qu'on réagisse
mais qu'on agisse et qu'on prenne
conscience encore une fois de la
fragilité aussi de ses droits qu'on
pensait irrévocable irréversible non ça
n'est malheureusement pas irréversible
et le dans la Constitution dans le socle
et bien c'est une vraie garantie sauf
que la proposition de loi que les
députés vont débattre que vous allez
débattre demain dans l'hémicycle elle
est déposée par les insoumis mais c'est
pour ça que alors berger avait réussi
son coup de com elle a pris les insoumis
de vitesse et puis elle a aussi pris la
lumière parce que forcément regardez la
photo dans le journal c'était pour qui
c'était pour elle et le gouvernement
plus arriver dans c'était juste après
les législatives avec un projet de loi a
priori proposition de loi a priori
capable de réunir une majorité une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle des
insomnies qui qui vient d'où alors elle
vient de loin elle vient de loin mais de
bien avant la décision de la Cour
suprême puisque en 2018 les insoumis
avaient déjà proposé
d'instruire le droit à l'avortement dans
la Constitution mais cette fois-ci
c'était pas pour réagir ce qui se
passait aux États-Unis mais en Pologne
ou le Parlement avait quasiment interdit
l'avortement donc c'est là que ça
devient un peu savoureux parce
qu'effectivement 2018 c'était il y a 4
ans tellement de choses ont changé
depuis par exemple à l'époque il y a une
n'était pas président de l'Assemblée
elle était président de la commission
des lois et à l'époque elle était pas
pour inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
elle était contre elle explique pourquoi
mon sens il est nul besoin
de la team à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays pour estimer que ces
droits seraient menacés dans le nôtre ça
n'est absolument pas le cas aujourd'hui
rien ne vous permet de laffirmer que
voulez-vous on appelle ça de la
politique ce n'est pas la girouette qui
tourne c'est le vent et un gars fort l'a
dit donc ça doit être vrai quelques
événements inquiets ce sont produits
depuis alors quels sont les différences
entre ces deux textes est-ce qu'il y en
a alors pour une fois qu'un texte de loi
est bref un seul article peu de mots on
peut les montrer en entier on peut même
les comparer tous les deux donc vous
voyez que celui des insoumis est un peu
plus long qu'il mentionne la
contraception la formulation n'est pas
la même ça son importance et formule
beaucoup plus brève pour Renaissance
mais le point commun entre les deux
formulations c'est qu'il y a aucune
question enfin on ne mentionne pas la
question du délai légal et ça c'est ce
qui inquiète les républicains Olivier
Marleix qui est le président du groupe
la rédaction qui proposait aujourd'hui
par le groupe de la majorité elle est
extrêmement maladroite puisqu'elle dit
en clair nul ne peut être privé du droit
à l'IVG en fait c'est faire
mais ça veut dire que le délai de 14
semaines il disparaît ça veut dire que
vous pouvez avorter n'importe quand
jusque jusqu'au terme je sais pas si
vous entendez le jeu il dit que les
républicains ne doivent pas être ringard
donc je pense que dans cet état d'esprit
là ils sont dit bon on peut nous aussi
inscrire il est déjà dans la
Constitution mais dans ce cas il
faudrait l'inscrire avec les délais
actuels transposer la loi veille dans
l'état actuel où elle se sachant que la
loi a été changée sur les délais très
récemment de 12 à 14 semaines de
grossesse et Marine Le Pen alors dans
tout ça est-ce qu'elle est très à l'aise
la semaine dernière c'était prononcé
contre l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution et puis cette semaine cette
fois-ci elle est plutôt pour elle-même
rédige elle-même un amendement qui est à
peu près le même que celui de
républicain donc pour maintenir la loi
telle qu'elle est mais l'inscrire dans
la Constitution alors c'est quand même
un peu bizarre ça balance mais vous
savez ce que disait la grande Martine
mettre des députés qui sont eux
militants de longue date contre
l'avortement ils sont produits comme
Christian et du coup qui est un élu de
hautmar et lui ben il a manifesté
longtemps contre droit à l'avortement
voilà ce qu'ils disent les français pour
pour les Français
c'est tout à fait qu'on se valable et
c'est absolument pas remettre en cause
l'idée même que l'avortement soit un
je dirais un génocide de masse donc lui
dit de masse vous disais je ne cite deux
masse mais en tout cas je vous rappelle
que Marine Le Pen elle elle est pour
inscrire les végé donc dans la
Constitution simplement elle comprend
très bien les gens qui sont contre on
l'écoute soyons sérieux personne ne
souhaite encore une fois toucher à la
loi maintenant qu'il y ait des personnes
qui ne se réjouissent pas cher Monsieur
de voir qu'il y a encore 200000
avortements par an en France c'est pas
critiquable donc pour résumer tous les
groupes parlementaires sont d'accord il
faut inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
en tout cas on peut le faire mais alors
au moment de débattre de la manière là
en revanche je crois qu'il y a des gros
différents entre vous donc je vous
laisse discuter merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane pour pour ce billet complet et
enlever d'ailleurs c'est vous
Jean-Philippe Tanguy qui est à l'origine
de cette inhi initiative de l'amendement
de Marine Le Pen on y reviendra mais je
voudrais commencer par cette question
toute simple est-ce que franchement vous
pensez que ce droit est menacé alors
peut-être pas aujourd'hui mais demain
est-ce que vous pensez que notre pays
peut basculer dans les mains je vais
dire d'un populiste quelconque quel que
soit le parti qui pourrait remettre à
l'image de ce qui s'est passé avec
Donald Trump à la Cour suprême en cause
ce droit fondamental pour les femmes
alors attendez je crois que vous savez
que si on avait posé la question aux
Américains et aux Américaines il y a une
dizaine ou une quinzaine d'années bon
nombre nous aurait dit que effectivement
il y avait aucun risque pour que
le droit à l'IVG puisse être remis en
cause aux États-Unis donc je crois pas
que l'argument soit valable et par
ailleurs mais c'est pas grave c'est une
question et par ailleurs je je là où
tout à l'heure vous disiez vous
compariez la situation et la posture
entre 2018 et 2022 moi je crois qu'entre
2018 et 2022 il faut rappeler qu'il y a
eu des élections et notamment des
élections législatives qui ont vu
arriver 89 députés du rassemblement
national à l'Assemblée nationale dont
certains vous l'avez dit qui considère
que l'IVG est un génocide de masse donc
je pense qu'il faut quand même être tout
à fait conscient de la réalité de la
menace donc vous craignez l'arrivée au
pouvoir du rassemblement national pour
ce droit c'est ce que je comprends je
crois que nous devons protéger le droit
de nous répondre aux jeunes filles
Sandra rogol y a-t-il un risque y a-t-il
un risque aujourd'hui y a-t-il un risque
demain alors là au moment où on parle il
y a une réunion qui vient de se finir au
Parlement européen à Strasbourg organisé
par le CLJ un collectif qui milite
contre le droit à l'avortement collectif
assez proche du parti de Monsieur Tanguy
et donc ce collectif organisait ce soir
au Parlement européen une soirée pour
travailler au moyen de faire tomber le
droit à l'avortement
en Europe et en France et juste avant ça
nous ont écrit à peu près tous les
députés on nous envoyant ce petit foetus
en plastique bonjour La cop27 pour la
pollution pour nous expliquer comment
c'était un danger comment est-ce qu'il
fallait arrêter de donner aux femmes ce
droit donc oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y a des forces qui ont énormément de
budget pour faire la promotion de la fin
des droits des femmes qui prospèrent
dans notre pays ça peut les gens
influencent pas du tout votre volonté
politique même si c'est une certaine
façon de pression voir
le fait d'inscrire ce droit dans la
Constitution je rajouterai à ça un
deuxième effet de ces collectifs
agissant c'est qu'aujourd'hui le droit à
l'IVG ils sont remis en cause pour des
femmes à cause de la clause de
conscience d'une part et ensuite dans de
plus en plus
de refuser de pratiquer une IVG et donc
aujourd'hui il y a qui nous disent il y
a pas de souci tout le monde veut que
les femmes conservent ce droit et je
réponds c'est faux tout est fait par
certains collectifs très largement
financés pour empêcher ça vous entendre
il y a presque une urgence
il y a une urgence à sanctifier dans la
Constitution ce droit des femmes a
disposé de leur corps et de leur vie
alors Jean-Philippe Tanguy même question
il y a beaucoup de choses faut-il au
fond protéger mettre à l'abri ce droit
définitivement pour les femmes dans la
Constitution je pense à Georgia Meloni
par exemple certes c'est pas dans son
programme mais dans sa grande coalition
que plutôt soutenue par Marine Le Pen
très clairement il y a des remises en
cause de l'avortement en tout cas de
l'accès de faciliter l'accès des femmes
à l'avortement est-ce que vous vous
considérez que ce serait un gros recul
si elle faisait ça m'éloé dites nous en
France on pense que oui c'est un recul
mais nous sommes souverainiste les pays
font ce qu'ils veulent dans leurs états
c'est la différence en Italie la
question des droits sociétaux elle est
aussi elle dépasse le clivage droit à
gauche si vous voulez qu'on parle de
l'Italie la place de l'Église catholique
en Italie n'est pas du tout celle de la
France et même à gauche pendant
longtemps par exemple le droit des
couples homosexuels à gauche était un
non dit en italien
sur l'avortement non mais parce que
voilà quand on voit mélonie certains
pensent à Marine Le Pen d'ailleurs elle
elle elle a dressait des ponts elle
s'est félicité de cette victoire donc on
se dit attention est-ce que ce serait si
Marine Le Pen arrive au pouvoir une
possibilité mais non mais pas du tout
reprenant les choses dans l'ordre pour
ce qui est des États-Unis chers
collègues le problème du droit à
Bordeaux aux États-Unis c'est une épée
de Damoclès qui est sur les États-Unis
non mais il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dites donc moi je sais pas
rétablir l'effet
de la situation
comme j'ai envie de répondre mais je
vais quand même le faire donc ça a été
une épée de Damoclès depuis 50 ans
puisque aux États-Unis les hommes
politiques et les femmes politiques
n'ont jamais pris leur responsabilité
pour qu'une loi fédérale remplace un
arrêt de la Cour suprême donc c'est pas
vrai de dire que il y a pas eu cette
épée de Damoclès États-Unis ça a
toujours été 55 ans donc ça n'a rien à
voir que la situation française où il y
a 95% des Français d'ailleurs on peut se
réjouir qui soutiennent la loi veille il
y a aucun groupe politique qui remet en
cause la loiveil vous pouvez avoir dans
les forces politiques c'était le cas
aussi à droite d'un Boutin par exemple
était encore ministre de Nicolas Sarkozy
jusqu'en 2012 qui ont toujours été
critiques ou contre le droit à
l'avortement ça n'a jamais été un
marqueur de parti politique c'était des
individus alors on va on va revenir dans
le détail sur la position qui a changé
de Marine Le Pen mais est-ce que vous
pouvez imaginer donc en France
aujourd'hui
par un changement d'avis sur la question
de la regarder
si vous vous
vous intéressez à nos électeurs nos
électeurs ont toujours été plus
favorables à la loi veille que les
électeurs de Heller c'est la sociologie
électorale qui fait que voilà donc c'est
pareil donc change d'avisait pas
l'inscrire celle-ci nous ne pensons pas
que juridiquement parce qu'il y a aucun
particulier qui le demande parce que les
Français sont très largement pour le
maintien du droit à l'accès à l'IVG le
l'IVG n'est pas menacé en France pour
des raisons juridiques il est menacé
pour l'accès aux soins pour l'accès à
les gynécologie pour l'accès à la
prévention pour l'accès à l'éducation
sexuelle qui nous a rejoint
dès les élections législatives mais il
n'est pas menacé juridiquement par
contre à partir du moment où le débat
vient au Parlement nous sommes des
responsables politiques il nous faut une
position politique donc ce qu'on dit
c'est si il doit avoir
consitutionnalisation c'est mieux de
mettre le droit actuel tel qu'il est
donc la loi veille et c'est
modifications
c'est un débat collectif et c'est Marine
Le Pen qui dépose amendement bonsoir et
merci d'être là la Maison des Femmes
vous avez raison de corriger que vous
allez fonder et dont vous êtes la
présidente bon vous vous êtes sur le
terrain vous vous connaissez la détresse
de ces femmes qui sont dans une
grossesse non désirée qui sont démunis
parfois qui n'ont pas de planning
familiale qui n'ont pas forcément les
délais qui nous ont pas respectés
comment comment vous vous regardez ce
débat vous dites c'est un débat purement
juridique où c'est un débat de fond
vraiment
un peu les deux c'est un débat juridique
très technique auquel je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas familière moi je me suis
intéressée à est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose de négatif à inscrire cette loi
dans la Constitution j'ai pas trouvé
donc je me dis puisque il n'y a aucun
effet néfaste à le faire et que
potentiellement ces sécurisant parce que
je partage les inquiétudes de mesdames
les députés pourquoi ne pas le faire
puisque on est tous d'accord que l'IV
vais-je en France ne risque rien que 80%
des Français sont pour et bien
faisons-le sécurisant parce que je ne
sais pas ce qui peut se passer dans 50
en disant dans 15 ans et je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
sécuriser quand on est aux abois alors
que là on pourrait peut-être avoir
quelque chose de très posé de très
tranquille et on ne menace personne de
ce que j'ai compris en l'inscrivant dans
la Constitution est-ce que les femmes
que vous rencontrez est-ce que c'est une
question qui se pose à la maison des
femmes se déballa qui a forcément des
échos dans la société
on aborde ce n'est pas différemment
c'est-à-dire qu'on se dit très bien
inscrivons-le dans la Constitution
sécurisant les femmes mais ça ne suffit
pas et je rejoins aussi ce que vous
disiez c'est à dire que l'inscrire si on
ne donne pas les moyens si on ne
développe pas la
l'orthogénie de proximité c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau donc à mon avis il
faut marcher sur nos deux pieds on
sécurise on donne les moyens on
regardera sur la réalité du terrain
aujourd'hui avec l'évolution législative
de 12 à 14 semaines mais on a quand même
le sentiment que il y a pas mal de
politiques derrière ces deux scènes de
textes bonsoir elles amandaï merci
d'être avec nous depuis les quatre
colonnes à l'Assemblée nationale vous
suivez ce dossier à l'Assemblée donc on
l'a dit deux textes distincts alors
qu'ils sont sensiblement
identiques il sert aussi un peu
d'instruments ce débat pour piéger
l'adversaire ou pas
oui exactement vous l'avez dit à Myriam
les deux textes sont le même objectif
mais on voit bien c'est des textes
courts ou chaque mot est vraiment
soupesé faut-il qu'il y ait le mot femme
ce qui peut exclure les hommes
transgenres faut-il une formule négative
nul ne peut ou une formule positive la
loi garantie voilà les différences de
rédaction mais l'objectif et le même la
gauche et la majorité sont un peu dans
une course pour apparaître et bien les
plus en pointes les plus progressistes
sur cette question du droit des femmes
et donc du droit à l'avortement et puis
il y a également vous en avez parlé la
volonté et bien de forcer leurs
adversaires à droite et au rassemblement
national et bien à se positionner sur
ces questions sociétés qui peuvent
diviser au sein de leur Majo de leur
groupe et au sein aussi de leurs
électeurs à droite on s'entente de s'en
tirer avec la loi veille ça permet de
rappeler Simone Veil elle était droite
même si c'est bien la gauche qui a
permis l'adoption de sa loi encore une
question Elsa sur le revirement ou la
nouvelle position de Marine Le Pen sur
sur cette inscription dans la loi
fondamentale vous avez des infos
coulisses sur ce qu'il a mené à faire ce
choix
écoutez vous en parliez Myriam Marine Le
Pen elle a toujours été très prudente
voir parfois embarrasser sur cette
question de l'avortement elle a donc
travaillé à la rédaction d'un amendement
c'est celui-ci l'amendement 190
Jean-Philippe tanguil disait il n'est
signé que par elle façon d'endosser la
responsabilité du choix du groupe et de
ne forcer personne à se positionner sur
la question il est assez technique
puisqu'en fait il propose d'inscrire
dans la loi non pas le droit à
l'avortement mais le droit actuel à
l'avortement l'inscrire dans le
préambule de la Constitution c'est donc
le premier du livre le titre premier du
Livre 2 de la deuxième partie du code de
la santé publique c'est quatre pages en
fait quatre pages qui règlement que le
droit à l'avortement en France avec
notamment ce délai à 14 semaines
pourquoi cet amendement et bien pour
trouver une position d'équilibre un
équilibre au sein de son groupe où il y
a des tradi conservateurs mais aussi des
députés et bien plus ouverts sur les
questions sociétales mais aussi pour
trouver de l'équilibre au sein de son
électorat un électorat féminin on le
sait pendant la campagne présidentielle
Marine Le Pen elle a joué cette carte
des femmes pour convaincre les femmes
vous allez voter des femmes on sait bien
sensibles à ce sujet de l'avortement
merci beaucoup Elsa mon dingava ont
duplex de la salle des quatre colonnes
au Palais Bourbon Sandra rogol c'est
vrai que il y a pas mal quand même
derrière penser politicienne autour de
ce débat on a pas un peu l'impression
que au départ la gauche également le
parti présidentiel avait trouvé là le
moyen de cornériser le rassemblement
national et au fond est-ce que c'est pas
lui qui qui vous piège aussi avec cette
nouvelle position de Marine Le Pen je
crois que ça fait longtemps que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
fait partie de nos fondamentaux vous le
disiez vous-même dans votre rappel c'est
pas la première fois qu'on dépose des
lois en ce sens là d'ailleurs la
première elle a été déposée au Sénat par
mélanivogel sénatrice écologiste il y a
quelques semaines donc vous pourriez
voter l'amendement Marine Le Pen
pour ça il faudrait qu'il soit rédigé
correctement en fait on n'a même pas la
Constitution en ajoutant des références
à des articles de loi c'est la
Constitution c'est pas une loi c'est un
texte particulier dans lequel on met des
principes et pas des articles
donc non je pourrais pas voter un
article qui est rédigé de façon
maltraiter la Constitution mais juste
pour finir cette promesse de
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'était une promesse de ce
gouvernement qui ne l'a pas tenu madame
borne elle-même est venue le dire
plusieurs fois et face à ça qu'est-ce
que font les députés de la nuit pèse
c'est une semaine après la vôtre
quelques jours à peine c'est lundi
prochain sauf Aurore berger la dépose
justement parce que le gouvernement
refuse de faire ce travail et de tenir
cette promesse c'est parce que nous la
nuit pèse acceptons de faire le travail
que ce gouvernement est encore une fois
incapable de faire donc c'est peut-être
politique mais et tout est dans le nez
vous disiez tout à l'heure madame que
tout le monde était d'accord pour
inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution je
suis en désaccord avec ça si tout le
monde était d'accord on aurait déjà
inscrit l'IVG dans la de la réalité
c'est que personne n'ose dire qu'il est
contre l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution et trouve énormément
d'excuses le délai des des formulations
qui n'iraient pas et que sais-je
d'autres pendant que nous bataillons
depuis des années pour inscrire enfin ce
droit dans la clair d'ailleurs on va
aller voir Serge Lama qui est
constitutionnaliste professeur de
République qui va nous dire quels sont
les chances de ces deux textes d'aboutir
mais d'abord Sarah tanzili vous êtes
d'accord au fond il y a un problème
d'écriture c'est ça c'est quoi ça
devient un gadget au fond ce on a ça
c'est quand même un peu un problème ce
sujet est très important
vous-même vous vous considérez que
l'amendement de Marine Le Pen n'est pas
bien ficelée je ne sais pas si c'est un
problème d'écriture ou si c'est un tour
de passe-passe qu'on est en train de
nous jouer parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez en renvoyant aux articles du code
de la santé publique qu'est-ce qui
empêcherait demain le législateur de
venir réduire considérablement
les conditions d'accès la gratuité il me
semble d'ailleurs que Marine Le Pen
avait indiqué qu'elle était contre le
remboursement des IVG considérant qu'il
y avait des IVG dites de confort on
pourrait aussi le disait en 2012 revenir
10 ans on pourrait aussi diminuer les
délais sans que ça pose
par exemple le moindre la moindre
difficulté puisqu'en réalité ce qui
serait constitutionnalisé c'est cet
article ces articles de loi qu'on
pourrait encore modifier donc c'est un
c'est un c'est un tour de passe-passe
qui
Jean-Philippe Tanguy il y a plusieurs
choses il y a la question des
avortements de confort cette expression
avait choquée elle est revenue dessus
donc elle était navrée si les personnes
avaient des femmes avaient été génocide
de masques quand même ça c'est un des
vôtres ce n'est pas Marine Le Pen mais
bon quand même mais ensuite il y a la
question il y a la question de ce que
vous voulez faire avec cet amendement
c'est compliqué de répondre à chaque il
y a beaucoup de questions qui me qui
reviennent mais j'avais répondu sur
monsieur Benz en citant vous pouvez
avoir des gens minoritaires dans votre
partie et par exemple qui qui
correspondent à des Français et par
ailleurs je suis moi je suis et il le
sait parce que j'ai déjà dit à
Christophe je suis complètement opposé à
cette formule que je trouve plus que
regattable d'ailleurs à titre personnel
condamnable à plusieurs gars mais vous
voulez faire avec la maman que ce soit
pas plus de 14 semaines le délai légal
ou pas ce qu'on veut c'est moi je
reviens à ce que je dis tout à l'heure
je pense que la question fait de l'accès
à l'IVG en France et c'est tant mieux et
moi ce qui me ce que je déplore c'est
qu'on se félicite pas justement que en
France ce soit une force d'être tous
d'accord là-dessus pour justement parler
de l'accès aux soins et de l'accès aux
droits réel c'est je l'ai le droit
actuel puisqu'il y a pas de débats
puisqu'il y a une grande majorité de
Français qui sont d'accord prenons le
droit actuel et
constitutionnalisant le tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui que c'est possible ça en
fait on voulait le charisme
de la santé publique on peut changer le
code de la santé publique ça fait du bon
sens juridique c'est pour ça que c'est
la situation droits et des principes et
pas des codifications de l'environnement
dans la Constitution par exemple qui est
en principe non c'est pas nécessaire et
donc en fait ce qu'on voulait faire nous
c'était chartisé le ce qui peut finir
une phrase le code pour non il y a la
charte qui en annexe madame de la
Constitution ce qu'on voulait c'était
chartisé cartilisé donc la loi le Code
de la Santé luxe soit une charte si vous
voulez du droit à l'IVG comme nous avons
un problème de de d'incertitude sur la
recevabilité on a fait seulement une
référence au code de la santé publique à
partir du moment où nos juristes à nous
et nos spécialistes du droit
constitutionnel on pensait que ça
sacralisait ce code et que donc la
protection constitutionnelle empêchait
de le modifier mais ce qu'il faut penser
c'est la position du groupe et la
position c'est par cet amendement c'est
de dire il faut geler la loi veille et
ses modifications postérieures ce qui
permet d'avoir une solution consensuelle
je pense que tout le monde est
aujourd'hui d'accord sur l'état de la
loi telle qu'elle est avec le code de la
santé publique et et en fait ne pas
ouvrir de nouveau combat parce que la
trêve que c'est très clair non mais ce
que disent les républicains ah juste ce
titre c'est que si il y a pas de délai
ce qui est qu'est-ce qui empêche demain
une fois qu'elle a Constitution qui est
votée de faire l'insulter
sur le terrain plus de 14 semaines on
est à 14 semaines aujourd'hui il y a
d'autres pays il y a le Royaume-Uni
c'est bien au-delà est-ce que ça vous
semble un délai c'est pas qu'elle
utilisait ce mot raisonnable le bon
délai pour pour les femmes en France
aujourd'hui où est-ce que vous vous
dites regarde du terrain un jour ou
l'autre il faudra se reposer cette
question du délai
alors la question la réponse est oui un
jour ou l'autre il faudra se la reposer
parce que en Europe nous ne sommes pas
les plus progressistes juste pour
revenir sur ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit que
les Français étaient à 80% favorable à
l'IVG et non pas à l'inscription dans la
Constitution je n'y connais rien je
pense qu'il faut se reposer la question
du délai et sans avoir peur de se la
poser qu'est-ce que nous apprennent les
chiffres la grande majorité des IVG sont
faites très vite très tôt les femmes
quand elles ne sont pas en difficulté
elles savent ce qu'elles veulent et
elles y vont et ce on a on a allongé le
délai et nous on faisait déjà dans le
cadre de la loi sur l'interruption
médicale de grossesse pour motif
médico-psychosocial on le faisait déjà
au-delà de 14 semaines et on sait ce
sont toujours des femmes qui ont des
situations particulières elles ont eu
leur elles ont été confrontés à des
conjoints qui les ont séquestré qui ne
voulaient pas qu'elles aient consulter
parce que eux voulaient garder l'enfant
elles ont été victimes de violences
conjugales une fois la grossesse
annoncée donc elles ont changé de projet
et ce sont ces femmes là qui ont besoin
d'avoir un délai plus long ça ne veut
pas dire que ouvrir le délai toutes les
femmes vont se dire tiens j'ai envie
d'avoir ta six mois c'est complètement
absurde de raisonner comme ça vous êtes
d'accord avec ça madame la députée
Renaissance j'insiste parce que il faut
quand même dire que cette loi qui porte
de 12 à 14 semaines le délai légal pour
avorter dans notre pays elle a été
portée par les députés mais pas par le
président Macron il était contre il
était contre au départ en tout cas il
n'a pas insisté pour mettre ce texte à
l'agenda c'était déjà l'initiative des
députés le point sur lequel je voulais
insister parce que je pense que autour
de cette question du délai et autour de
de la proposition qu'essaye de défendre
le député Tanguy il y a la question de
savoir est-ce qu'on constitutionnalisant
ce droit on va rentrer dans un
dispositif un texte qui ouvrirait un
droit inconditionnel
moi je tiens quand même à le préciser il
n'y a pas de droit ou de liberté
inconditionnel la liberté d'expression
elle est consacrée dans notre
Constitution et pour autant l'ingure
publique les propos racistes les propos
négationnistes sont interdits par la loi
et le juge constitutionnel c'est déjà
prononcé là-dessus il l'a dit c'est
compatible donc je ne crois pas qu'il y
a un vrai sujet sur la question des
délais tels que tel qu'on le rédige
aujourd'hui je pense que ça c'est très
important de le dire on n'est pas en
train d'ouvrir
le droit à l'avortement à huit mois de
grossesse ça n'est pas du tout ce que
nous sommes en train de faire nous
sommes en train de constitutionnaliser
un principe de garantir le fait que dans
notre pays de façon effective et de
façon libre nous pourrons continuer à
pratiquer l'IVG voilà Sandra rigole je
voudrais quand même rajouter un point
parce qu'on l'a pas beaucoup évoqué on a
parlé des divisions mais pas de ce qui
rapproche là ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
y a deux textes effectivement mais il y
a la volonté de la des deux côtés
d'arriver à voter à faire en sorte que
l'une des deux passe à l'heure c'est les
députés ils vont trouveront votre texte
celui des insoumis de la nuvette et
inversement et c'est pour autant nous
faisons notre travail de législatrice et
de législateur c'est à dire que nous
travaillons à l'améliorer mais il y a la
volonté collective de dépasser les
questions partie d'air et d'appartenance
de la personne qui a déposé le texte
pour arriver à inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution et pour autant c'est que
nous ne sommes pas suivis par tout le
monde alors justement on va terminer ce
débat et je vous redonnerai la parole
c'est promis Jean-Philippe Tanguy avec
professeur de droit public à Grenoble
merci d'abord Serge Lama d'avoir été
patient vous êtes à distance avec nous
en visioconférence très concrètement
quels sont les chances d'aboutir de ces
deux propositions de loi qui vivent donc
à inscrire ce droit dans notre
Constitution
bonsoir je suis plus spécialiste du
droit des libertés que
constitutionnaliste des champs sont
assez faibles d'une part parce que les
trois propositions sont très mal à
droitement rédigés je pourrais y revenir
si vous voulez et puis par ailleurs si
ce sont de propositions elles doivent
être soumis au peuple français donc il
faudrait que ça soit adoptant tellement
terme conforme par les deux assemblées
mais surtout se met au référendum c'est
pour ça qu'il serait mieux d'avoir un
projet de loi déposé par le Gouvernement
ça simplifierait les choses pour qu'une
proposition de loi qui modifie la
Constitution soit adoptée il faut
qu'elle soit adoptée à terme identique
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat le Sénat
étant de droite très très peu de chances
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer alors faute
d'accord au Sénat c'est le président de
la République qui doit déposer avec le
gouvernement un projet de loi
constitutionnel et là quelle est la
suite de la procédure
toutes les façons si c'est une
proposition c'est très souvent au peuple
français en revanche si c'est un projet
ça peut être ensuite soumis au Congrès
avec une majorité qualifiée mais
vraiment il s'est pour l'instant les
trois textes sont mauvais puisque c'est
formé en termes absolues d'une femme ou
une personne on peut refuser un femme ou
une personne le droit à l'avortement et
la proposition du rassemblement national
est absurde puisqu'on peut pas se
renvoyer au code de la santé publique on
peut renvoyer à des longs antérieurs
1946 on peut effectivement constituer
constitutionnaliser une charte comme on
l'a fait pour la Charte de
l'environnement mais par envoyer un code
actuel il faut envoyer une loi
spécifique au principe d'une loi
spécifique donc le mieux c'est garantir
un droit positif c'est dire qu'on
garanti dans les conditions déterminées
par la loi le droit l'avortement avec
une référence un délai d'au moins 14
semaines d'accord dernière toute petite
question rapidement monsieur Slama il y
a des pays qui l'ont fait en Europe par
exemple ou pas très peu en fait c'est
plutôt l'inverse c'est qu'il y a des
pays qui ont inscrit l'interdiction de
l'avortement directement indirectement
dans leur constitution et c'est pour que
ça serait c'est vraiment important
aujourd'hui pour la France d'inscrire ce
droit expressément comme un droit de
toute personne à l'avortement dans les
conditions déterminées par la loi avec
ce délai de 14 semaines merci beaucoup
Serge Lama professeur Slama en droit
public à Grenoble en fait on se demande
un petit peu pourquoi tout ça si ça n'a
peu de chance d'aboutir Jean-Philippe
Tanguy
le Sénat que l'on pourrait semblance ne
va pas
la proposition de loi
c'est pour ça que je serais moins
possible
de droits
personnellement Jean-Philippe Tanguy si
votre amendement est rejeté vous votez
quand même l'un des deux textes les deux
mais les deux oui mais le nouveau trait
donc voilà on apprend des choses les
lignes bougent donc vous voterez le
texte en streaming mais vous
personnellement
à sa place je ne sais pas je n'ai aucune
idée
moi je voterai pour les deux bon moi mon
idée pas de position de groupe non il y
a une liberté sur les questions
sociétales moi c'est surtout pour
envoyer en fait un signal aux femmes du
reste du monde dire vous avez des pays
comme référence qui peuvent vous aider
dans votre combat qui sont
que vous voulez comme accompagnant voilà
je pense que toutes ces femmes qui
luttent dans le monde a besoin de de
pays qui les soutiennent moralement à
défaut de pouvoir les soutenir ok la
consultation du peuple vous la souhaitez
de toute façon nous on a toujours dit
par contre on voulait que les questions
sociétales soient tranchées par le
peuple donc oui nous on sera favorable à
des on préfère que le peuple s'exprime
plutôt que le que le Parlement mais la
difficulté il faut quand même répondre
là-dessus c'est que de la même façon
pour le Sénat on peut aussi écouter les
républicains si disent que même veulent
bien concessionnaliser la loi veille bah
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait pas une
charte comme j'ai proposé qui reprend
les principes tels que le droit à son
maintenant comme ça tout le monde est
d'accord on fait un projet qui rassemble
imaginez quand on arrive à faire
ensemble des LFI jusque LR et avec le RN
bon ce serait quand même bien d'avoir un
projet comme ça même pour envoyer un
donc pourquoi est-ce qu’on le fait pas
Assemblée nationale Senna puis le peuple
français saratanzelli les chances
d'aboutir alors sur les chances
d'aboutir je partage ce que disait ma
collègue c'est à dire que la marche
n'est pas si haute et que il convient de
mener les combats les uns après les
autres d'abord à l'Assemblée nationale
ensuite au Sénat et ensuite vous savez
nous sommes des parlementaires nous ont
avec les moyens dont nous disposons donc
on utilise une proposition de la
constitutionnelle mais on pourra bien
évidemment avoir des discussions avec le
gouvernement pour aller vers un projet
pour que un projet de loi voilà prennent
la suite si ces textes n'arrivaient pas
au bout ce serait plus serein le mot de
la fin on a vraiment besoin de cette
constitutionnalisation de ce droit de
droit positif des femmes à disposer de
leur vie ça paraît essentiel ça paraît
normal on est le pays des droits de la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme merci le pays des Droits Humains
bah écoutez évidemment LCP va suivre ces
deux débats celui qui aura lieu donc
jeudi dans l'hémicycle dans le cadre de
la niche des insoumis et celui qui aura
lieu lundi prochain pour la majorité
présidentielle merci à tous merci Gada
Hatem d'être venu sur le plateau LCP
pour pour ce débat merci également au
professeur Serge Lama d'avoir été à
distance avec nous on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin pour son 86e
livre rendez-vous compte Jacques Attali
nous livre une nouvelle histoire
mondiale cette fois c'est celle de
l'éducation et comme à chaque fois il se
plonge dans le passé pour tirer des
leçons pour l'avenir alors comment notre
école accusé de tous les mots doit-elle
évoluer comment transmettre aussi dans
un monde de plus en plus complexe
comment s'adapter aux métiers de demain
Jacques Attali nous rejoint juste après
l'invitation d'Hélène ponctuel
si on vous invite Jacques Attali vous le
polytechnicien énarque passionné par
l'histoire de nos sociétés c'est pour
nous aider à savoir si l'on fait fausse
route dans notre éducation je crois que
c'est le rôle principal des enseignants
c'est de faire la plupart des réussites
c'est de faire que l'enseignement soit
un lieu de plaisir de découverte et
visiblement vos enseignants vous ont
donné le plaisir des mots économiste au
fonctionnaires chefs d'entreprise vous
êtes aussi un écrivain prolifique vous
avez écrit plus de 80 ouvrages et dans
le dernier histoire et avenir de
l'éducation voudraient le panorama
mondial de notre système éducatif depuis
3000 ans en réalité l'histoire des
formes de transmission du savoir et la
France est loin d'être exemplaire Didou
en France on se situe au pire endroit en
termes de modèles parce qu'on a le pire
du système compétitif
et punitif parce que on note très jeune
on désigne les mauvais vous suggérer
dans votre livre de prendre exemple sur
les systèmes éducatifs de nos voisins de
robes du Nord notamment la Finlande pour
vous il faut également valoriser la
profession d'enseignants c'est une de
vos préconisations mais plus surprenant
comme s'instruirait socialement
indispensable vous émettez aussi l'idée
de récompenser toute personne qui
apprend vous êtes également partisan
d'une plus grande autonomie donnée aux
établissements une idée qui se rapproche
de l'école du futur lancée à Marseille à
la rentrée par Emmanuel Macron sais-tu
se dire face à tous les défis qui sont
les nôtres et qui sont
très différent d'un territoire l'autre
comment on arrive à faire mieux
travailler toutes les parties prenantes
et au fond donner tout à la fois plus de
moyens mais plus de liberté aussi
pédagogique aux enseignants en lien avec
les parents d'élèves avec le
périscolaire avec les élus pour au fond
rétablir cette égalité des chances qui
est la promesse républicaine l'école
n'est qu'un des acteurs de la
transmission de la connaissance elle
doit cependant être repensée dites-vous
de manière hybride pour former à ces
métiers de demain ce qui n'existe pas
encore sur l'écologie la
cybercriminalité ou bien la
biotechnologie mais alors Jacques Attali
pour former à ses nouveaux métiers pour
une connaissance mieux partagée à quoi
doit ressembler notre salle de classe de
demain et d'ailleurs est-ce que ce sera
toujours une salle de classe
bonsoir Jacques Attali merci beaucoup
d'être fidèle à cette émission ben voilà
première question cette classe de demain
elle sera elle sera où elle sera dans
une école ou pas forcément dans quel
pays on parle dans la plupart des pays
du monde aujourd'hui il y a pas d'école
où il y a des écoles de très mauvaise
qualité avec un point pour santé élève
des élèves qui sont sur le sol et des
profs qui sont pas des pays d'Afrique je
parle l'essentiel de l'humanité en fait
et donc à peu près 60 à 70% ne sont pas
du niveau selon selon l'Unesco et c'est
pareil en Inde c'est pareil pour large
partie de la Chine du large partie de
l'Amérique latine ou bien se dire ça
dans les pays les plus développés dans
dans 20 ans et dans les
pour les classes moyennes supérieures
supérieures ou dans les pays qui ont
réussi une égalité remarquable comme la
Finlande qui est vraiment
avec 15 élèves par classe
avec l'accès à toutes les technologies
avec des professeurs qui seront aussi
bien payés que les meilleurs médecins ou
les meilleurs avocats avec des
programmes qui seront très librement
choisis par les profs dans un ensemble
de
projets avec une
enseignement collaborative avec surtout
surtout c'est ça qui va être nouveau à
mon avis c'est ce qu'on a ce que
j'appelle les colis brides c'est-à-dire
qu'on fera classe une partie à l'école
mais pas dans l'école
où on est en partie en télétravail en
partie
en plus que ce que l'histoire m'apprend
et c'est pour ça que quand j'écris des
livres sur l'avenir j'essaie de
comprendre le passé
le passé montre que l'école ressemble
toujours à la façon de travailler dans
l'entreprise les ateliers c'était des
écoles un peu des ordres l'école
d'aujourd'hui c'est le travail à la
chaîne les élèves qui passent d'une
classe à une autre comme les voitures
qui passent d'un poste de travail à un
autre et aujourd'hui on va vers un
travail hybride on est de temps en temps
chez soi de temps en temps ailleurs de
temps en temps sur le travail et ce sera
pareil alors j'ai une question parce
qu'on va revenir sur sur l'histoire
parce que c'est toujours très riche
d'enseignement pour pour penser l'avenir
qu'est-ce que l'éducation pour vous
qu'est-ce que vous mettez derrière ce
mot vous rendez hommage à de nombreux
professeurs qui ont été déterminants
pour vous d'ailleurs vous les citer nos
mémément en introduction vous dites ce
qui les réunissait c'est la passion de
transmettre est-ce que c'est ça
l'éducation d'abord j'ai appelé ce livre
Histoire et à venir de l'éducation au
pluriel mais j'aurais pu si le titre
n'aurait pas été trop paniqué ambigu les
appeler histoire et à venir de la
transmission parce que l'éducation au
sens de l'école
n'est qu'une face immergée ou émergée
selon les cas de la transmission qui se
fait qui s'est fait très longtemps que
par la famille pour 90% de l'humanité
par le travail pour les enfants qui
allaient travailler à partir de l'âge de
6 ans par les forains
jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle d'ailleurs
la transmission des savoirs se fait plus
en dehors de l'école il y en a très peu
elles sont réservées à pertinent l'école
est réservée
aux hommes de l'église
de toutes les églises c'est on forme les
gens d'église où on forme les gens au
savoir religieux ou quelques
serviteurs des pouvoirs l'école est un
moyen de pouvoir plus exactement l'école
est en train de réplication du système
social et ça change un peu partie du un
peu à partir de la réforme et un peu à
partir surtout à partir de du milieu du
19e siècle quand en particulier aux
États-Unis et dans quelques autres pays
il faut former tout le pays c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir à quel
point le clergé en Europe a tout fait
pour restreindre au maximum l'accès au
savoir les gens n'ont pas d'accès
évidemment à l'écriture lire et compter
c'est réservé à des à des élites il y a
une constante aussi c'est les femmes
dans l'histoire et ça quelle que soit
les modèles de civilisation et de
culture elles sont écartées
systématiquement de tous les sables
depuis l'antiquité la plus ancienne les
femmes sont écartées la moitié de
l'humanité n'a pas eu droit à savoir
est-ce que ça tient sans doute à ce que
les hommes
ont peur des femmes et comme l'école est
là pour maintenir le système en place il
faut pas que les dévions les marginaux
et les femmes sont de ce point de vue à
l'égard du système en place des
déviantes et des marginales faut pas que
c'est accès au savoir et c'est d'être
fascinant j'ai retrouvé je raconte très
brièvement quelques biographies de
femmes qui ont réussi à passer à travers
les barrières il fallait vraiment des
qualités de caractère de compétences
extraordinaire pour pour passer à
travers et en effet on a perdu pendant
000 millénaires au moins alors les
compétences avant de parler de notre
système au combien critiquer très mal
classé dans le fameux pizza les
meilleurs les meilleurs modèles vous
avez deux modèles d'ailleurs très
différents la Finlande vous avez
commencé à nous en parler 15 ans élèves
par classe avec des professeurs très
bien payés et puis et puis la Corée du
Sud alors là c'est l'inverse énorme
pression pour des résultats extrêmement
brillants mais c'est ça il y a un
système ça renvoie aux deux idéologies
dominantes de notre temps qui sont
l'altruisme et l'individualisme
l'altruisme c'est travaillé ensemble
comprendre qu'on a intérêt à coopérer
faire des projets ensemble ne pas faire
de du classement de la hiérarchie une
valeur alors que le système Coraline Sud
qui est en fait l'héritage du système
chinois de 3000 ans qui s'est poursuivi
jusqu'au jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est les concours c'est l'obsession de
la sanction c'est la note à partir de
l'âge de 2 ans c'est l'obsession qui
conduit à des résultats extraordinaires
mais en même temps à des suicides des
inégalités parce qu'il faut que les
parents puissent payer des cours
complémentaires la sanction c'est
forcément une absurdité
si on peut l'éviter oui
nous disons la compétition par la note
avec l'évaluation
tous les systèmes d'éducation depuis
l'antiquité la plus ancienne de
transmission en antiquité jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est répétitions sanction
récompense toujours été ça et il faut la
sanction c'est quand on a échoué c'est
que alors que si on crée des mécanismes
d'encouragement
système finlandais on a la preuve il y a
pas de sanction il y a pas de notes
encore une fois jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans
alors parlons de notre modèle au fond
vous dites on cumule les difficultés
c'est le pire des systèmes compétitifs
et c'est le pire des systèmes laxistes
vous êtes très sévère malheureusement
les résultats de de pizza c'est-à-dire
de l'OCDE le CD est une des meilleures
institutions internationales des plus
crédibles qui donnent des statistiques
très corrects qui fait des études très
approfondies avec beaucoup d'objectivité
et les études de l'OCDE j'ai pu
travailler avec plusieurs de leurs
experts montre que non seulement nous
sommes pas bons mais nous sommes tomber
dans tous les domaines de que ça soit
des universités que ça soit de du niveau
de scolaire des enfants en mathématiques
en lecture etc mais aussi sont revenus
ils ne sont plus nous options mais
c'était intéressant là encore a d'abord
pour que ça fasse effet il faut du temps
et ensuite c'est vraiment terminale
tandis que là il s'agit de des
mathématiques en 6e et enfin c'est
encore plus mauvais si on regarde
simplement la question de la justice
sociale nous sommes un des pays où il
faut le plus de temps un élève d'une
certaine classe sociale pour atteindre
une autre classe sociale et c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui donne un autre pays ce
sentiment de de recul c'est qu'un des
parents ne peuvent plus croire que leurs
enfants auront une meilleure vue que
tout simplement vu que parce que l'école
le leur garantit pas alors est-ce qu'on
a les moyens d'ordre le coup à tous
réalité là parce que il faut beaucoup
d'argent c'est beaucoup d'argent il faut
voilà une volonté politique massive
une philosophie différente
nous on a construit une école depuis
l'école catholique du troisième siècle
de notre ère jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur
l'autorité on va vous enseigner ça vous
avez le droit de savoir que ça d'abord
que ça de religieux puis quand ça a
basculé dans la société que ça dans la
laïcité avec les batailles que je
raconte évidemment entre l'Église
catholique et les collègues mais toutes
les deux avec le même obsession
n'enseigner que ce qui doit être
enseigné donc il n'y a pas de confiance
dans le droit de faire autre chose
d'apprendre autrement de trouver ce
pourquoi on est bon de collaborer avec
les autres on transversale or quand on
fait confiance le grand risque c'est une
perte de contrôle nous sommes dans une
société la société française qui a
terriblement peur de perdre du contrôle
cette philosophie là à certains
enseignants l'ont déjà adapté sur le
terrain il y a ces enseignants à Drancy
je sais pas si vous connaissez ce cette
expérience absolument
ou les parents sont impliqués ou il y a
des règles
on parle de lui dans le livre il est sur
son expérience où les parents les
enfants et les enseignants collaborent
mais non seulement c'est une réussite et
il y a un documentaire qui est en train
d'être finalisé sur son travail et
maintenant il est en train de
ces méthodes donc finalement par le
terrain par les enseignants on peut
changer plus les choses que par la
volonté politique c'est très bien mais
ça fait très longtemps qu'il y a des
expériences magnifiques quand il y a au
premier siècle de notre ère je cite ces
textes ça devrait être on pourrait le
dire aujourd'hui comme les plus avancés
Pestalozzi au 18e siècle
Montessori au début du 20e siècle
freinait dans les années 1920 et bien
d'autres encore il y a eu toujours déjà
en avance mais en France comme ailleurs
il faut un système global la Finlande
pourquoi elle l'a fait parce qu'elle a
fait table rase du système ancien ça va
pas
la même chose une des réformes majeures
et on est aussi on est un petit pays
comparé au grand pays du monde on est un
petit pays bien sûr que c'est possible
merci beaucoup Jacques Attali comme
d'habitude je vous renvoie vous voyez
bien qu'il y a encore beaucoup de choses
à piocher à apprendre dans cette
histoire et à venir de l'éducation au
pluriel et vous allez voir ces
passionnants c'est aux éditions
Flammarion vous restez avec moi Jacques
Attali on va accueillir nos affranchis
pour leur partie prix à présent ce soir
la mienne verte du quotidien Blick
Richard Verly qui va revenir sur ce qui
se passe à Mayotte Mayotte au bord de la
guerre civile l'oeil sur le numérique de
Delphine Sabatier ce soir elle nous dit
attention si vous êtes supporters au
Qatar et bien vous êtes surveillé
Delphine Sabatier de bismart bien sûr
enfin la grande porter au Figaro
Isabelle Lasserre le regard sur la
guerre qu'elle apporte ce soir nous dit
que les Américains et bien oui
pourrais-je dire pourrait arrêter de
vibrer leurs armes aux Ukrainiens on a
besoin d'en savoir plus bonsoir les
affranchis bonsoir et merci d'être
Richard vous dit revenir sur la
situation dramatique à Mayotte depuis le
12 novembre des batailles rongées entre
bande rivalshem la peur et la désolation
dans l'île tous les élus tirent la
sonnette d'alarme et ce soir vous poser
la question une question qui fâche la
France défi à Mayotte peut-elle encore
prétendre être une puissance mais oui
parce que si on prend un peu de recul et
qu'on se pose la question au niveau
européen et bien est-ce bien raisonnable
pour la France une puissance qui est
quand même confrontée depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine aux limites de son
influence dans le monde de continuer à
gérer cette île de 374 km2 qui est situé
je le rappelle au sud de l'archipel des
Comores et au nord de Madagascar et si
oui alors pourquoi les autorités
françaises apparaissent à ce point
déborder par cette violence qui est
attribuée vous l'avez dit par les élus
de Mayotte surtout à des bandes de
jeunes immigrés et clandestins venus des
Comores qui contrôlent des quartiers ou
des villes et ce livre à des Vendetta de
plus en plus féroze alors cette question
je la pose parce que beaucoup de voisins
de l'hexagone et bien il se la pose
aussi il y a une crise économique et
sociale en Europe est-il possible
viables souhaitable de conserver à
l'autre bout du monde des territoires où
l'autorité républicaine n'est plus
vraiment en mesure de s'exercer alors
faisons un petit exercice allez par
exemple expliquer un Hongrois ou un
Polonais Myriam vous savez leur pays
sont en conflit avec la Commission
européenne allez leur expliquer ce qui
se passe à Mayotte montrez-leur les
images avec ces jeunes qui sont en train
de s'étriper à coup de machette essayez
par exemple avec un chinois essayez avec
un indien alors comment croire vu ce
naufrage insulaire au premier
géopolitique de la France dont Emmanuel
Macron a inventé la semaine dernière au
G20 de Bali et au sommet de la Pecq à
Bangkok la vocation d'être un acteur
dans la zone indopacifique une zone qui
justement va de l'océan Indien
c'est-à-dire de Mayotte jusqu'à
l'Extrême-Orient de là quand même
abandonné Mayotte à sa violence écoutez
je souligne jusque le fait qu'il s'y
passe n'est pas seulement un problème
pour ses habitants pour eux et c'est
extrêmement grave et pour leur sécurité
la France se présente comme une
puissance globale mondiale en s'appuyant
sur ces territoires d'outre-mer
notamment dans la zone Indo-Pacifique
alors que deux facto elle peine à les
contrôler et que certaines situations
deviennent même ingérables rappelons
aussi rappelons aussi quelques faits
historiques Mayotte c'est la seule île
des Comores à avoir par référendum en
février 1976 choisi de rester français à
99% des suffrages mais que c'était-il
passé juste après et bien comme par
hasard le mercenaire français Bob Donard
avec une garde pretorienne était arrivée
aux Comores qui venait de voter pour
leur indépendance il y était devenu une
sorte de proconsult pendant plus de 10
ans maîtrisant entre autres les fameux
flux migratoires c'est une époque
heureusement révolue mais la question
demeure à 8000 km de l'Hexagone le
drapeau français flotte sur un
territoire synonyme de chaos et de
pauvreté le supposé miracle de la
puissance française est peut-être à
Mayotte un mirage qui ne trompe plus
personne jaquette pour le plaisir de la
conversion je suis entièrement désaccord
parce que vous oubliez qu'il y a la
Réunion juste à côté qui est territoire
français extrêmement Pacifique
extrêmement heureux avec beaucoup
d'inégalités beaucoup de chômage mais en
même temps un développement exceptionnel
donc ce qu'on a réussi ce qu'on réussit
tous les jours à la réunion avec
beaucoup de difficultés doit réussir à
Mayotte je connais bien les gens qui
vivent à Mayotte c'est difficile il y a
des professeurs il y a des hauts
fonctionnaires il y a des gens qui
vivent il y a pas de raison de renoncer
à Mayotte ce qu'on a réussi ce qu'on est
en train de réussir tous les jours à la
réunion
de la Réunion donc
l'avocats
au sens de Tahiti de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui est jusqu'à
présent se passe très bien la chronique
de Delphine Sabatier va vous intéresser
forcément vous qui connaissez si bien
les évolutions du numérique si vous êtes
supporters au Qatar Delphine vous êtes
surveillé
en tout cas c'est mieux d'éviter d'y
aller avec son portable chargé
d'informations parce qu'aujourd'hui en
fait le problème dans le monde dans
lequel on vit c'est que ces petits
appareils sont hyper vulnérables à tout
ce qui est vol de données attaque
surveillance espionnage alors je voulais
vous montrer une carte elle a été
réalisée par l'autorité de protection
des données personnelles en France et
vous voyez le Qatar est dans une couleur
plutôt Parme alors c'est pas ce qu'on
fait de pire en matière de protection
des données voilà ça apparaît c'est pire
en matière de protection des données
personnelles mais enfin on est juste un
cran en dessous ça veut dire qu'en fait
les règles en la matière là-bas ont été
jugés par l'Union européenne comme non
adéquate alors c'est pas la plus
mauvaise nouvelle en plus qui attend le
1 million et demi de supporters qui va
s'y rendre et puis tous les journalistes
aussi qui est en train qui sont en train
de couvrir l'événement sur place ah bon
qu'est-ce qui arrive
c'est que quand on arrive au Qatar le
gouvernement qatari nous impose de deux
applications or ces deux applications
ont été catégorisées par les experts de
la cybersécurité comme étant des
logiciels espion c'est à dire qu'elles
peuvent accéder à l'ensemble des données
de nos smartphones de manière totalement
invisibles et elles peuvent même les
utiliser alors ce qui est recommandé
dans ce cas là et bien c'est pas
uniquement de ne pas avoir de
smartphones mais il y a tout un tas de
précautions à prendre l'acnil sans effet
les cours à l'occasion d'une interview
apolitico et puis on a aussi notre
ministre du numérique Jean-Noël Barrault
qui a lui tweeté quelque chose du genre
bien en France en Europe vous avez le
règlement sur la protection des données
personnelles mais pas de telles règles
au Qatar alors quelles précaution
doit-on prendre donc si on veut pas
vivre sans smartphone qui est ce qui est
je conçois devient compliqué on peut en
acheter un neuf vierge en prépayée
jetable on peut aussi se dire avant de
partir finalement je vais me faire une
petite sauvegarde ici je pars avec mon
smartphone sans rien à l'intérieur c'est
un peu une démarche fastidieuse dans
tous les cas quand on est sur place il
faut absolument s'éviter de se connecter
à des sites qui nous demandent de nous
authentifier parce que là ça veut dire
que je pense à si par exemple de banques
de e-commerce ça veut dire que on va
confier nos mots de passe on va confier
des informations supplémentaires assez
logicielles espions ce qu'on peut faire
aussi c'est surveiller ce qu'on partage
sur les réseaux sociaux les photos les
vidéos parce qu'il y a des lois très
contraignantes là-bas ça peut attirer
les autorités si on en fera là encore
certaines règles et puis enfin quand on
rentre à Paris ou chez soi et bien je
vous conseille de désinstaller
automatiquement ces deux applications
qui vous ont été imposées plus largement
il faut désinstaller toutes les
applications qui ne vous sont plus
utiles dont vous n'avez pas besoin et
même je vais plus largement que vous
alliez à doigt ou pas je vous conseille
cette check-list de la CNIL en cas de
voyage parce que c'est vrai que en
Europe en France on a ce règlement sur
la protection des données il existe mais
en revanche son application ça reste
toujours une gageure donc il est
aléatoire selon les pays forcément on
est et même et même ici en France son
application aujourd'hui du rgpd elle est
compliquée donc faut apprendre à
protéger nous-mêmes nos smartphones bon
merci beaucoup vous protéger vous allez
sur télégramme et toutes les messageries
extrêmement sécurisées
et en effet faire ça tout le temps si je
peux me permettre d'ajouter Delphine qui
a une autre solution en plus
de demain notamment ceux qui sont liés à
la cybersécurité vous vous en parlez
également Jacques Attali dans votre
livre Isabelle
Isabelle Lasserre après 9 mois de guerre
les stocks d'armes occidentales auraient
atteint leur point critique jusqu'à
remettre en cause l'aide à porter aux
Ukrainiens y compris l'aide américaine
oui c'est une inquiétude en tout cas qui
grandit à Kiev bientôt l'armée
américaine en tout cas ne pourra plus
sans doute fournir les équipements de
pointe quel fournissait jusque là à
l'armée américaine alors l'aide
américaine ne va pas s'arrêter mais elle
pourrait ralentir et elle pourrait être
composée de de matériel beaucoup plus
anciens pourquoi il va tout simplement
parce que les réserves américaines
arrivent alors limite en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les munitions la guerre en
Ukraine est une guerre très très
consommatrice en équipement et elle dure
depuis 9 mois un exemple au plus fort
des combats l'été dernier les forces
russes il leur est arrivé de tirer
jusqu'à 600 000 obus par jour les forts
sucréniennes 20.000 depuis 24 février
aussi le Pentagone a fourni plus d'un
million d'obus à Kiev et les Américains
aurait transféré à l'armée ukrainienne
le tiers de leur missile antisa Javelin
c'est énorme et pour que le rythme se
poursuive il faut reconstituer les
stocks et ça prend du temps parfois
plusieurs années pour certains
équipements et l'Europe est bien sûr
dans la même situation c'est même pire
c'est bien pire parce que parce que
persuadé que la guerre avait été chassée
du continent à la suite du communisme et
de l'effondrement du mur en 1989 et 91
les européens se sont désarmés ils ont
profité des dividendes de la paix et ont
baissé de manière parfois spectaculaire
leur budget de la défense alors il y a
que deux pays Grande Bretagne et la
France qui avait réussi à maintenir une
armée de qualité mais encore là avec un
modèle beaucoup plus réduit qu'avant
alors les seuls combats en plus auquel
ces pays ont participé sont des combats
de moyenne intensité ou des guerres
asymétriques alors l'Iran l'Irak le
Kosovo l'Afghanistan mais il ne peuvent
pas suivre aujourd'hui sur la distance
quand il s'agit de soutenir à long terme
une guerre de haute intensité comme
celle que mène la Russie en Ukraine
alors quelles peuvent être les
conséquences pour l'Ukraine s'il est
livraisons d'armes ralentissent c'est
très simple sans les armes américaines
qui représentent environ les trois
quarts de l'aide militaire
internationale la perspective d'une
victoire ukrainienne s'envolerait les
responsables Ukrainiens seraient sans
doute contraint au compromis par leur
occidentaux ils devraient dire adieu
alors espoir de récupérer rapidement la
Crimée mais il n'y a pas que les stocks
qui inquiète les responsables Ukrainiens
il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle la fatigue
de la guerre qui pourrait venir à
l'issue d'un hiver difficile l'in la
hausse des prix des deux côtés de
l'Atlantique c'est pour ça que les
Ukrainiens veulent aller vite et qu'ils
veulent même essayer d'aller très vite
comment vous voyez ce conflit est-ce que
est-ce que ça vous inquiète pour les
Ukrainiens à ralentissement des
livraisons
d'arts je peux me permettre exact mais
il faut aussi dire que du point de vue
c'est pareil parce que les rues sont en
train de voir disparaître on a quasi
totalité de leur propre armement ils
essaient de bricoler avec les Iraniens
quelques petites choses et les Coréens
de faire
mais en réalité il y a c'est comme deux
gladiateurs
gravement blessé et on ne sait pas quel
est le premier qui va mourir si vous
lisez un grand nombre de spécialistes il
vous explique aujourd'hui de façon assez
convaincante que l'économie s'est touché
à mort et qu'il va pas tenir mais vous
avez tout à fait raison si on arrête les
livraisons aux Ukrainiens c'est fini il
y a aussi une autre cause qui va arriver
dans les jours qui viennent c'est le
froid qui fait que peut-être deux à
trois millions d'ukrainien vont quitter
l'Ukraine vous quittez l'Ukraine pour
aller en Pologne en Allemagne parce
qu'on ne peut plus vivre dans ces
conditions donc ces deux blessés graves
de blesser grave mais quelques raisons
d'espérer quand même pour les pour les
Ukrainiens on va garder cette note
d'optimisme merci à vous merci les
affranchis et merci infiniment Jacques
Attali d'être venu sur le plateau de LCP
histoire et à venir de l'éducation
c'est-à-dire chez Flammarion très belle
soirée bien sûr sur LCP puisque c'est
votre documentaire qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même lieu
même heure
[Musique]